bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du 78 lactu sur TVfil
78 dernier journal de la rédaction pour
cette semaine en ce vendredi 4 avril
voici les titres quelquesuns des
principaux sujets qui vont être
développés lancement aujourd'hui de la
20e édition du S d'action 20 ans de lut
contre une maladie qui aujourd'hui
inquiète malheureusement moins et
pourtant chaque année on dénombre près
de 3 millions de nouvelles
contaminations de par le monde afin de
sensibiliser l'opinion des opérations
sont organisées sur le terrain le club
de généalogie racine va organiser ce
weekend sa réunion annuelle afin de
faciliter le travail de ses membres mais
aussi de présenter ses résultats au
grand public cette année à H encour un
travail particulier a été mené sur la
guerre 1418 à l'occasion du centenaire
et puis comme chaque vendredi retour sur
les principales inf formation de la
semaine une actualité marquée par la
politique entre remanement du
gouvernement vague bleue au municipal et
départ du président du conseil général
des
ZBL à l'occasion du lancement de la 20e
édition du S d'action de nombreuses
opérations sont organisées sur le
terrain des jeunes se mobilise à Montini
le Bretonneux ou encore à encour yolen
Torz et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud le S d'action fait ces 20 ans
l'année dernière 40000 personnes ont pu
être mises sous traitement grâce au don
récoltés par l'association de lut contre
le VIH jusqu'au 6 avril plusieurs
actions de mobilisation se déroulent sur
le territoire au lycée des cartes de
Montini le bretonux les élèves élus au
Conseil de la Vie Lycéenne aidé des
infirmières et des CPE tiennent un stand
d'information et vendent des objets si
d'action l'occasion de sensibiliser les
lycéens à cette maladie c'est quelque
chose qui la sexualité qui a uncore un
tout petit peu tabou je dira uncore au
lycée et donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
les pousser parce que c'est vraiment à
ce moment-là qui est le premier rapport
sexuel les pousser à se protéger et à
sensibiliser sur d'action et aussi un
peu tout ce qui est MST en rapport avec
le programme de de scienceces qui qu'on
peut avoir en première ou en fonction
des des filières inciter à la protection
et au dépistage un message que
l'association tente de faire entendre
aux jeunes pas toujours bien informé sur
le sida ça se passe pas dans ma
ville pas dans mon pas dans mon
environnement mais
c'est enfin je sais que je sais ce que
ça fait à des milliers de kilomètres
parce que les dégâts que ça peut faire
je me sens pas personnellement con mais
je sais que ça doit être une maladie qui
peut faire beaucoup de ravage et
franchement ça me fait de la peine pour
les personnes qui l'ont en terme de
contamination chez les jeunes
l'association hchef Prévention parle de
chiffres alarmants là récemment on a eu
une étude d'une mutuelle étudiante qui
annonçait que 30 % des jeunes ne mettent
pas le préservatif donc dans les
universités nous on constate que
effectivement 30 % c'est national en
Île-de-France par exemple on aurait
plutôt tendance à dire que c'est plutôt
50 à 60 % présente lors du forum santé
elle en cours cette semaine
l'association a informé les collégiens
de la ville sur le sujet et le message
semble être bien passé il faut bien se
protéger que faut connaître la personne
avec qui euh on va avoir un rapport et
voilà il y a des gens qui qui se qui
sont inconscients de bah de ce que l'on
peut de ce que de ce qu'il risque s'ils
se protègeent pas et il y en a qui
trouvent que ça le arrivera pas mais ça
peut ça peut arriver à n'importe qui
donc
faut que tout le monde
soit soit prudent prudent il faut bien
entendu le rester malgré les progrès
réalisés depuis les 20 années
d'existence du Sidaction aujourd'hui
grâce aux trithérapie on ne meurt plus
du sida mais le combat est loin d'être
terminé il y a aussi beaucoup d'effets
indésirables donc quand on prend donc
ces médicaments faut pas oublier que ce
sont donc des bombes chimiques he qui
font que le virus est contrôlé mais mine
de rien cette bombe chimique fait que
les gens peuvent vivre beaucoup plus
longtemps et on fait tout pour qu'ils
soit soit dépisté tôt pour être
effectivement traité tôt parce que plus
on traite tôt et c'est les nouvelles
recommandations plus on va traiter tôt
plus on va gagner en
durabilité les membres de l'association
achèv Prévention et leurs bénévoles
seront tout le weekend à 5quenttins en
Yveline pour collecter des dons dans la
rue et à la gare RER vous pouvez
également appeler gratuitement le 110
jusqu'au 15 avril alors vous prenez
aussi les petits modes d'EMP prenez le
féminin aussi le sida qui chaque année
rappelons-le encore fait de nombreuses
victimes ni le vaccin ni le traitement
ver véritablementexiste encore avez-vous
toujours peur de cette maladie c'est
notre question du jour vos réponses non
enfin j'ai pas spécialement peur du sida
parce que on a eu assez d'informations
dessus pour pour savoir comment s'en
protéger on sait qu'il y a des m des
médicaments pour fair des traitements
pour PIR le palier on a peur de
l'attraper donc on se protège et voilà
je suis marié depuis très longtemps et
que et que voilà quoi ça se passe bien
dans mon couple donc je me sens pas
concerné plus que ça alors peut-être
qu'près avec les enfants effectivement
je verrai à ce que ça se passe bien
socialement oui le sida je pense qu'on
en entend quand même assez parler donc
non pas trop inquiété par ça c'est déjà
une maladie avec laquelle plusieurs
personnes appviennent à vivre plusieurs
années Moon j'ai pas pe du sida je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut se protéger mais
faut toujours être prudent rappelons que
le Sidaction fait donc ces 20 ans 300
millions d'euros ont été collectés
reversés à la recherche et au soins à la
prévention et à l'aide aux malades à
travers toutes ces années pour vos dons
un site internet dédié bien évidemment
et puis un numéro de téléphone le
papa c'est moi ça va chérie papa je suis
serositive
allez n'oubliez pas le 110 tout au long
du weekend la 14e journée du sommeil se
déroul le 28 mars un mauvais repos peut
en effet avoir de graves conséquences
sur la santé prise de poids diabète
augmentation de la douleur ou dépression
pour apprendre à se détendre une
technique trouve un écho de plus en plus
favorable auprès de la population la
sophrologie yolen
Torz à l'occasion de la 14e journée
nationale du sommeil le 28 mars dernier
l'association équilibre énergie de mon
le Bretonneux proposer une conférence et
des ateliers objectif détailler les
mécanismes du sommeil et faire découvrir
la sophrologie l'occasion pour les
spécialistes de donner quelques bons
conseils pour atténuer le stress ennemi
numéro 1 du sommeil et savoir se
relâcher avant de dormir c'est surtout
d'apprendre à reconnaître les signes les
signes effectivement du sommeil par
exemple les baillements lesclinements
des paupières le moment où on va être
complètement on avoir ce coup de barre
et arriver justement à reconnaître ces
temps et à S adapté à ces temps-là
suivre son rythme de sommeil ça c'est
très très important puisque sans sommeil
et bien nous ne tenons pas beaucoup au
niveau de la journée c'est très très
compliqué pour nous au sommeil c'est
vital pour un être humain en moyenne les
25 et 45 ans déclarent en effet avoir
besoin de 7h30 de sommeil pour être en
forme le lendemain la
mélatonine invité de ce journal à
présent Joël Nizard bonsoir vous êtes le
président du club de généalogie racine à
El encour morpa 27 ans d'existence pour
ce club et ce weekend nouvelle édition
de vos rencontres généalogique c'est à
la maison de quartier de la ville Dieu à
hencour donc et pour débuter peut-être
pour rassurer aussi le grand public on
va préciser qu'on ne va pas trouver sur
place des arbres généalogiques de toutes
les familles qui seront posés exposés de
cette manière c'est beaucoup plus vaste
que ça absolument quand on parle de
rencontre généalogique ça peut faire
peur à certaines personnes qui sont pas
spécialisées dans la
généalogie en fait la la généalogie ce
n'est pas simplement remplir des cases
et faire des Abes pour remonter des
branches mais c'est également et ça on
on le voit très très vite étudier la vie
de nos ancêtres donc nous exposons
beaucoup de panneaux nous avons en total
400 panneaux dont la grande majorité ont
rien à voir disons avec des arbres
généalogiques h ça concerne par exemple
l'histoire les métiers anciens nous
avons énormément de panneaux sur les
métiers anciens la place de la femme
public même si on n'est pas passionné de
généalogie même si on n' pas fait son
propre arbre généalogique on peut venir
se documenter passionné de généalogie
même si on connaitt rien la généalogie
qu'on veut pas faire de
généalogie C exposition son très
intéressantes et on s'ennuira pas il y a
énormément de choses à lire sur
l'histoire et la vie de nos ancêtres
soit les métiers la position de la femme
dans la société et ainsi de suite on va
voir quelques images des précédentes
éditions qui vient justement sur place
pour vous rencontrer ce sont justement
des des gens qui aussi veulent peut-être
des conseils pour se lancer dans les
dans les recherches parce que faut être
un peu initié il faut avoir des
techniques pour pouvoir rechercher et
surtout réussir à trouver les bonnes
informations donc effectivement il y a
de deux types de personnes il y a ceux
qui sont passionnés de géogie donc qui
vont trouver aussi leur bonheur parmi
toutes les associations externes qu'on a
fait venir puis il y a aussi des
personnes qui vont découvrir ou qui
connaissent pas du tout la géologie mais
qui vont apprendre disons par nos
panneaux l'histoire laavis des longcours
j'ai oublié de dire que nous non
seulement nous faisons exposition
géologie mais aussi nous faisons
exposition sur la Guer 141 oui on va y
venir justement dans un instant parce
que c'est important à l'occasion de du
centenaire de cette grande guerre vous
avez travaillé on va le détailler dans
un instant mais à propos toujours
vraiment de la généalogie à un moment on
parlait d'un d'un boom de la généalogie
vraiment des gens qui se passionnaient
de plus en plus peut-être par le climat
un petit peu compliqué actuellement de
de crise qui se passionnit pour cette
recherche de ses ancêtres savoir d'où on
venait tout simplement aujourd'hui ça se
confirme encore combien de personnes
font partie de votre confirme encore dis
notre association est en perpétuelle
expansion euh actuellement nous sommes
106 je crois quand j'éta vous voir il y
a 2 ans on était un peu en dessous de
100 donc on augmente de 10 personnes
près chaque année ça prouve que c'est
effectiv encore en plein boumin votre
club se réunit régulièrement comment
vous travaillez justement à quoi
consiste une séance du club racine ah
c'est un peu compliqué donc en fait nous
avons plusieurs séances et que ça a
changé au fil du
temps initialement il y avait qu'une
seule séance c'était le lundi qui était
uniquement un tour de table donc
progressivement donc on a un peu changé
donc on a toujours le tour de table mais
on a orienté cette séance par l'exposé
d'un thème ensuite n onons éprouvé le
besoin de former les personnes notamment
à l'informatique et la génologie savoir
qu'en géologie maintenant on utilise
beaucoup de ressources informatiques ce
qui a permis de simplifier les
recherches permis de simplifier les
recherches maintenant on peut quasiment
faire du moins en grande partie sa
géologie dans son fauteuil donc nous
avons très vite éprouvé le besoin de
former certaines personnes parce que
tout le monde est pas très jeune
enassociation faut bien le dire donc on
a eu besoin disons de former les ces
personnes à la généalie et à
l'informatique donc nous avons des
ateliers qu'on appelle atelier de
géologie d'informatique le vendredi
après-midi nous avons également des
ateliers de paléographie le jeudi
après-midi donc la paléographie pour
ceux qui connaissent pas c'est apprendre
à à décrypter l'écriture ancienne h et
nous avons maintenant depuis peu encore
une nouvelle séance d'informatique le
mardi après-midi donc on a quatre
séances par semaine ce qui est énorme et
comment se prépare ce ce rendez-vous
annuel que vous organisez celui qui se
tiendra ce weekend comment ça se se
prépare combien de temps vous vous
mettez et qui travaille dessus oh ça se
prépare presque 3 ans à l'avance en fait
c'est un petit projet euh comme dans
une entreprise hm hm mis à part que ça
se manage de manière tout à fait
différente donc on travaille en petit
groupe chaque groupe est autonome sa
responsabilité ça marche très bien par
exemple mon équipe actuellement est en
train de monter l'exposition
l'exposition à découvrir ce weekend à en
cours alors vous l'avez mentionné il y a
aussi cette année tout un travail qui
sera présenté autour de 1418 la guerre
de 1418 à travers l'histoire des des
poilu des poilu et l' courtois comment
vous avez vous ê parti du monument
Mor en fait absolument on est partie du
monum mort parce que on ne traite que
les poilus morts pour la France donc
ceux qui apparaissent sur le monument
mort donc nous avons commencer par
relever les noms des poilu sur le monum
monument mort ensuite nous avons cherché
donc leur fiche matricule que l'on peut
obtenir facilement maintenant sur un
site internet qui s'appelle mémoire des
hommes pour voir un peu quel était leur
parcours au niveau disons
militaire et nous avons essayé de
trouver aussi leur
parcours leur vie à travers les
documents de la mairie vous avez r tout
leur parcours vous en savez plus
aujourd'hui on va découvir plus sur ça
dépend ça dépend des il y a une dizaine
de poilu on y est arrivé quasiment pour
tous les poilus donc ils ont chacun un
panneau individualisé avec leur histoire
et leur parcours pendant la guerre 14 et
où ils sont où ils sont décédés quel
régiment ils étaient ce qu'ils ont fait
leur Grad où ils sont nés il y a des
choses qui vous ont marqué lorsque vous
avez découvert des sur l'histoire de
1418 sur l'histoire de ces personnes
aussi qui du jour au lendemain ont dû
partir à la guerre quelque chose que
l'on oublie au fil au fil du temps ce
qu'on oublie quand même au fil du temps
5 1418 et et on se rite on se rend vite
compte quand on l'étudie h c'est
l'orreur de cette guerre h il y a eu
quand même plus d'un million 1300000
morts dont pour la première fois
beaucoup de civils il a eu 300000 civils
c'est donc c'est c'est ce qui apparaît
très très vite quand on étudie disons un
peu l'histoire de cette guerre quand on
revient un peu sur cette guerre et vous
aurez bien évidemment de nouveaux
éléments toujours à découvrir a en cours
pour ces rencontres généalogiques avec
le club racine merci d'être passé sur ce
plateau nous présenter cette exposition
le montage se déroule actuellement
vendredi et demain ce sera ouvert au
public sur de jours et nous reviendrons
bien sûr sur cette rencontre
généalogique dans dans nos prochaines
éditions du journal merci encore Jo
mzard d'être venu sur ce plateau
merci nous allons donc revenir sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
une actualité forcément marquée par la
politique et les nombreux changements au
niveau local premier de ces changements
le basculement de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline à droite le
Parti socialiste perd son bastion
historique à ISU des municipales
Catherine
zulaton l'agglomération cinquantinoise
bascule à droite une première depuis sa
création en
1973 à l'issue de ce second tour des
municipales 25 sièges échouent au
candidats qui pent les couleurs de la
droite et 23 à ceux qui portent les
couleurs de la gauche et ce alors que
les communes conservent leur couleur
politique guyancour trappe et manilamo
restent socialiste la verrière
communiste hencour demeure UMP Montini
divers droite et Alexandra Rosetti udi
en porte voisin le Bretonneux quatre
villes à gauche trois villes à droite
une particularité qui va influer sur le
mode de gouvernance comme l'estimait
Michel logier le maire de Montini
dimanche soir sur notre plateau on a euh
beaucoup d'atout à Saint-Quentin on a
beaucoup d'atout à Saint-Quentin moi je
souhaite surtout que justement que euh
cette agglomération soit surtout un
outil pour les pour les communes et
qu'on réussisse ensemble et pas euh que
ce soit comme ça l'a été il y a quand
même pas mal de temps un outil plus
politicien euh en direction euh de de
certaines formations politiques tout
simplement donc là moi aujourd'hui je
suis pour plus de clarté plus de de
transparence et euh effectivement que
tout le monde soit associé on a cette
nouvelle gouvernance à à inventer euh je
pense malgré tout collectivement même si
ça sera à la charge de celui qui euh ou
de celle hein visiblement de celui qui
euh sera la tête de l'agglomération de
faire des propositions mais forcément il
faudra inventer quelque chose pour euh
réussir à sortir de cette situation un
peu étrange effectivement quatre villes
de gauche peuvent être euh en avec trois
villes de droite et avec une majorité
quand même de sièges pour la droite
l'agglomération cinquantinoise à droite
c'est une révolution politique certes
mais pas tant que cela car les écarts
entre la droite et la gauche ont
toujours été serrés par exemple pendant
les 16 années de gouvernance de Robert
Cadalbert la répartition était de 22
sièges pour la gauche et 20 pour la
droite la différence entre un projet de
gauche et de droite on le sait on sait
ce que c'est c'est effectivement un
projet où on accueille pour tout le
monde une mixité sociale
des servic publics de qualité on conna
les grands fond entre la gauche et la
droite mais sinon moi je suis sûr que
les élus quel qu'il soit la direction de
de cqutin ils auront envie que ça
continue et que ça continue à réussir
à il faudra encore patienter plusieurs
jours pour connaître le nom du futur
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération attendre déjà
l'installation des conseils municipaux à
Trapp et à voisin le Bretonneux le
nouveau conseil communautaire doit se
réunir avant le 30
avril et pour prendre la présidence de
cette nouvelle agglomération c'est le
nom de Michel logier qui est le plus
souvent cité le maire de montiné le
Bretonneux qui était sur ce plateau
cette semaine voici quelques extraits de
son intervention dans une démocratie il
y a des personnes
représentatives plus que d'autres donc
aujourd'hui il y avait deux euh maires
qui sortaient un petit peu du lot
j'allais dire qui était Jean-Michel
Fourgous et et moi-même puisque Alexis
Biet aurait pu être aussi celui-ci
aurait pu prétendre donc Alexis ette
ayant été non élu sur sa ville et bien
donc il en revenait je pense aux deux
maires principaux de partir à la
conquête de cette agglomération à la
tête d'une nouvelle majorité donc on
s'est entendu avec Jean-Michel sans
aucun problème avec aussi l'accord
j'allis dire de la future mère de voisin
broteneux donc les choses se sont
passées en toute transparence et euh on
a décidé d'un commun accord que c'était
celui qui pouvait le plus rassemblé pour
le but c'était aussi de pas croisser
l'opposition c'était aussi de pouvoir
mener des des rapports peut-être vous
avez de meilleurs rapports avec la
nouvelle opposition de la communauté
d'agglomération que Jean-Michel Fourgous
écoutez il y a plein de de critères mais
je crois pas que on fait pas par rapport
à quelque chose on fait par celui qui
peut incarner le mieux un nouveau projet
il y a aussi une question de crédibilité
mais je veux dire Jean-Michel était
aussi tout à fait à même de
pouvoir prétendre à conduire à cette
majorité il s'avère qu'après différentes
analyses différentes différents critères
ire que nous avons pris en compte bien
j'étais celui qui correspondait
peut-être le plus pour porter cette
nouvelle majorité on sait déjà très bien
ce que l'on veut et en tout cas pour ce
qui concerne le domaine économique
puisque c'est celui auquel vous faites
allusion nous avons toujours un
territoire attractif et nous souhaitons
qu' qu'il soit encore plus vous savez au
cours de C des dernières années on a
aussi travaillé que ce soit sur H encour
sur Montini à l'arrivée de belles
entreprises et je pense que ce qui s'est
passé notamment sur la commune de
Montini ne peut que encourager toutes
les personnes qui souhaitent venir et en
tout cas croire en notre idéal
économique sur 50 effectivement il faut
qu'on crée de la richesse il faut qu'on
crée des emplois et jusqu'à présent
c'est vrai que on a la chance d'être
dans un territoire attractif et je pense
que la balance entre les emplois qui
sont créés et ceux qui peuvent
disparaître hélas est largement positive
sur 50 aneline en poste depuis 2009
Alain Schmitz a donc annoncé mardi son
départ de la présidence du Conseil
Général des ielin retour sur son
parcours avec ce
reportage 2009 Alain Schmid s'estélu
président du conseil général des yvelin
26 ans après son entrée en politique en
tant qu'adjoint à la culture à
Versailles représentant du canton de
Versailles Nord depuis 1994 et en charge
une fois de plus de la culture il
succède à Pierre Bédier forcé à
démissionner en raison d'une
condamnation le rendant inéligible une
condamnation qui n'écorne pas l'image
qu'il avait de lui le qualificatif que
que j'utiliserai qui me vient
spontanément à l'esprit c'est un un
sentiment d'admiration pour ce qu'il a
fait pour sa ville de monte- laajolie
pour le Montois et puis pour le
département il a été visionnaire il
était visionnaire pour sa ville il a été
également pour le moi et il l' été tout
autant pour le département proche de ce
dernier alin schmidz doit malgré tout
annuler l'un de ses projets
emblématiques la création d'une piste de
Formule 1 à Flin Pierre Bédier
souhaitait depuis plusieurs années déjà
une vallée de l'automobile et de la
mobilité durable Alain Schmith va
ensuite au cours de ces 6 ans de mandat
exercer sa priorité œuvrer dans le
social en créant notamment ne9 esp pass
territoriaux pour les demandeurs
d'emploi les personnes handicapées ou
les senniors et durant toutes ces années
il continuera également à exercer son
métier de commissaire priseur voulant
garder une activité dans le civil pour
se ressourcer ancien sénateur en
remplacement de Gérard Larcher appelé en
2004 au gouvernement il a donc choisi
aujourd'hui 1er avril d'annoncer sa
démission une démission effective dans
une dizaine de jours Anan Schmitz qui
s'est longuement expliquer devant la
presse sur les raisons de ce départ et
sur l'arrivée programmée de son
prédécesseur Pierre Bédier prédécesseur
qui avait d quitter son poste en raison
d'une condamnation pour corruption
passive et recelle d'abus de biens
sociaux voici quelques extraits de
l'interview accordée à TVfil par Alain
Schmitz l'intégralité est à retrouver
sur notre site
internet Alain Schmitz bonjour vous avez
annoncé mardi 1er avril que vous alliez
quitter au 10 avril à la présidence du
du conseil général alors d'abord
pourquoi ce ce choix qui est un peu
étonnant parce que il y a quelques mois
quand le conseiller général du canton de
Montini François vous AAZ posé la
question vous aviez dit non non je
resterai jusqu'au bout de mon mandat il
vous restait un an à faire oui parce que
je ne voulais en aucun cas que cette
décision qui était prise depuis
longtemps je vous expliqueris dans quel
contexte puisse interférer avec les
élections municipales considérz que ça
n'était pas le sujet s posé le problème
de la réforme territoriale de
l'émergence de la métropole euh du
devenir de nos départements de grande
couronne et je me suis dit qu'il n'était
pas normal que je n'évoque pas que je
n'assume pas la responsabilité de ma
succession en laissant en quelque sorte
la place libre le lendemain des
élections de 2015 C étaé inconcevable
qu' ait pas de patron à la barre du du
navir rivelim si vous voulez le 11 avril
précisément séance du conseil général
sera euh désigné élu le nouveau
président du conseil général on on parle
de père bélier confirm oui je le
souhaite personnellement parce que de
tous mes collègues je suis sûr que c'est
lui qui fera euh certainement euh la
plus grande unanimité au sein de sa
famille politique il est fort de de son
expérience qui est reconnu de sa
compétence de son engagement au service
des ivelines il l'a montré en d'autres
temps il le montrera dans l'avenir sans
aucun doute et comme je vous l'ai dit
c'est une période particulièrement
troublée institutionnellement parlant
que nous allons traverser avec de
grosses difficultés en terme de
ressources financières pour le pour le
département et il fallait quelqu'un qui
puisse faire entendre la la voix
discipline et que fera Alain Schmitz
après le 11 avril ah alors d'abord jeis
continuer mon mandat de conseiller
général de versaill et puis je vais
œuvrer et je souhaite continuer à œuvrer
au service de des 160 communes rurales
du département parce que ces communes se
sentent un petit peu orphelines dès lors
qu'elles ne sont pas dans la métropole
et donc j'espère être celui qui pourra
continuer ce ce combat au service des de
nos plus petites communes merci alin
scHit d'avoir rép question merci merci
autre événement politique cette semaine
l'annonce du nouveau gouvernement Liv
Linois Bonois amont il figure toujours
élu dimanche dernier à attrape au
conseil municipal dans la majorité de de
guimalandin élu également pour siéger à
la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin il a été nommé ministre de
l'Éducation nationale de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche un poste
stratégique au regard des enjeux dans ce
domaine pour le bassin ivelinois élu
député de la 11e circonscription des
iveline en juin 2012 Benoît Amon n'a
encore jamais siégé au Palais Bourbon
membre du gouvernement de François
Hollande à l'économie sociale et
solidaire il doit comme le prévoit la
loi laisser la place à son suppléant
Jean-Philippe my et en ce 2 avril ce
dernier voit son séjour se prolonger
puisque c'est au poste de ministre de
l'éducation de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche que vient d'être
nommé celui que l'on présente comme
l'homme fort de l'aile gauche de la
gauche Benoît amont également élu
dimanche conseiller municipal à trappe
sur la liste de guimalandin et
conseiller communautaire à Saint-Quentin
en Yveline mais il siégerait alors dans
l'opposition au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale qui regroupe dorénavant celui
de l'enseignement supérieur Benoît
amamont est très attendu sur la question
des rythmes scolaires notamment lancé
par son prédécesseur Vincent payon une
réforme que de nombreux M refuse
d'appliquer en septembre et notamment
l'un de ses principaux rivaux
Jean-Michel Fourgous ma d'élancour à
boisarcy celui qui vient de ravire la
ville au PS Philippe benasaya annonce
aussi mettre en suspend la réforme et
puis sur le plan local toujours que dire
de l'Université de Versailles
saint-quontin en Yveline que la
dorénavant ancienne ministre jeunevev
fiorasso accusé de mauvaise gestion
poussant l'État à intervenir pour
combler un déficit mettant à mal sa
survie là aussi les prochaines
déclarations de Benoît Amon sont pour le
moins attendu dans le département par
les principaux concernés qu'il soit en
syndicaliste président d'université ou
tout simplement étudiant et benoîont est
attendu ce vendredi soir attrape pour
l'installation du nouveau conseil
municipal de guimalandin nous en
reparlerons bien sûr lundi à 18h en
direct d'ici là excellent
weekend